One way to improve the accuracy of pathway
analysis is to use the best of both of these
methods.
We can use an enrichment approach to score
the pathways and then we also score the pathways
using a topology-based approach that identifies
how perturbed that particular pathway is.
The benefit of this is that you are less likely
to have false positives because you're now
using two different types of evidence to score
each pathway.
Under this model, the enrichment approach
first assesses the abundance of significant
genes in the dataset.
For example, if we have 20,000 genes in our
dataset.
After we threshold for significant genes either
by fold change or by p-value, we are left
with approximately 10% of the genes as being
significantly differentially expressed.
Based on this overall abundance of significant
genes, when we look at any pathway, we would
expect to see 10% of the genes in that pathway
to also be significant just by random chance
alone.
But if we see more than 10% of significant
genes in a pathway, then we consider that
pathway is enriched.
It has a greater number of significant genes
than we would have expected by chance alone.
This is how the enrichment model approach
works.
You'll notice that the pathway diagram does
not have any interactions because this method
does not consider the interactions among genes
in the pathway.
Any kind of enrichment analysis approach,
a pathway is just a bag of genes.
Now let's talk about how we calculate how
perturb that pathway is.
In this particular model, we take the fold
change for a given gene that was observed
in our data and then based on its position
and its role in the pathway, we take that
fold change that was observed and we propagate
it to the next gene that's directly downstream
of it.
And then we propagate it again to the next
gene until we reach the end of the pathway.
These interactions could be activation or
could be inhibition and the model take those
into consideration and do the signal changes
that are appropriate.
The model even takes into consideration when
one gene signals multiple genes that are downstream
or if we have several genes that concentrate
their signal onto a single gene.
Each one of those situations is taken into
consideration.
The model does that for each and every single
significant gene on every single pathway in
our dataset.
Then the model sum all of the gene level perturbations
to assess how perturb the overall pathway
is.
This is a much closer approximation to how
we would assess the pathway from a biological
perspective rather than just counting the
number of significant genes.
Let’s look at how this works on a real pathway.
In this example, we have a single significant
gene in this particular pathway.
Here, we're looking at the insulin signaling
pathway.
The way the enrichment model is going to assess
this pathway is it's going to count the number
of significant genes.
In this case, we have one significant gene
and it's going to compare that to the total
number of about 50 genes in the pathway.
So, our ratio of significant versus non-significant
genes is 1 out of 50.
This the major limitation of the enrichment
model where the model may conclude that 1
out of 50 genes is not significantly enriched.
It also does not recognize whether the significant
gene that we input in is located at the very
up stream or down stream of the entire pathway.
Both of those situations have the exact same
ratio of significant genes to non-significant
genes in this pathway.
Therefore, the enrichment model would not
be able to tell the difference between these
two situations.
But as biologists, we can tell that this in
the situation where the significant gene is
at the end of the pathway is very different
then if the gene is at the beginning of the
pathway.
Let's look at the same example from a perturbation
perspective.
Here, instead of just counting the number
of genes, we're also going to look at the
interactions.
If we zoom in on this particular significant
gene we see that it's going to have a direct
impact on the upper cascade at the top of
the pathway, the genes in the central part
of the pathway, and also the genes in the
lower part of the pathway.
If we take this fold change, in this case,
we have a 5 fold change in expression and
we propagate it to all of the downstream genes
until we can't go any further, we see that
this one specific gene is going to affect
all of the other genes in this particular
system.
This makes sense because this is the main
entry point to this particular system.
Therefore, when we sum up all of the gene
level perturbations, we would be able to identify
that this pathway is highly perturbed given
this one significant gene because it is crucial
in the regulation of this particular system.
We would not be able to identify that using
an enrichment model.
Now, let's contrast this example with a slightly
different example.
Here we're seeing the adherence junction pathway.
We have the same insulin signaling receptor
in this particular system.
If we were to assess this from an enrichment
model, again we have one significant gene
out of roughly 50 genes contained on this
pathway.
We will see the exact same ratio as in our
previous example.
The enrichment model would not be able to
tell the difference whether this pathway is
more important to us or the previous pathway.
The model would score relatively the same
because it has the same number of significant
genes versus the total number of genes on
the pathway.
But when we look at the interactions among
genes in this particular system, we see that
in this case, the insulin signaling receptor
does not propagate its signal to any other
genes in this particular system.
In this system, the receptor plays a much
less crucial role.
If we try to assess how perturb this pathway
is, we're going to see that this pathway is
much less perturbed and therefore much less
significant compared to our previous example.
This is the key difference between analysis
of pathways from an enrichment model versus
a perturbation model.
One way to overcome these discrepancies is
to use both forms of evidence.
In this two-way plot, we'll see on the horizontal
axis we have the minus log of the p value
that came from the enrichment analysis approach.
What that means is those pathways with a lot
of evidence for being enriched are over the
right-hand side of this graph.
We also score the pathways using the perturbation
model.
The minus log of the p value that came from
that perturbation analysis is plotted on the
vertical axis.
So those pathways with a lot of evidence being
perturbed will be along the top edge of this
graph.
Ideally, we want to find those pathways that
have both types of evidence.
They will be located in the brown section
of the graph and those pathways are least
likely to be false positives because they
have confirming evidence from both types of
approaches.
For example, here is an actual plot of a data
set that we analyzed.
We will see that we have a pathway over here
that has a lot of evidence for being enriched.
Again, all that means is it has a large number
of significant genes that are contained on
this particular pathway.
Here we have a pathway that has a lot of evidence
for being perturbed but it's not very enriched.
Again, what that means is that there are probably
some key genes that are responsible for the
regulation of this particular pathway.
Now, here is our number one pathway in this
particular example.
This particular pathway has both types of
evidence.
It is the most perturbed pathway and it also
happens to be one of the most enriched pathways.
So this is probably the first pathway that
we want to look at when assessing pathways.